[Applause]
it's tom brady in his 10th super bowl
appearance taking on patrick mahomes and
the kansas city chiefs
call me lamar jackson because i might
[ __ ] myself with excitement
it's tom brady versus the baltimore
ravens
just when you thought life couldn't get
any crazier since 2020
the cleveland browns are in the super
bowl they're led by full-time commercial
actor part-time nfl quarterback baker
mayfield
and stay tuned after for dancing with
the stars
will six-time champion juju
smith-schuster continue his streak
who knows but if i hear corvette
corvette
one more time i'm gonna quit
broadcasting and go
live in the woods
coming to you live from dosh coin arena
it's yet again
tom brady this time against baylen
breeze
ken baylin surpasses dan drew's super
bowl record of
one i guess we'll find out
live from my underground bunker it's a
family affair
as surprise surprise tom brady takes on
his old team
the new england patriots led by none
other than his own son
jack brady no matter who wins it's sure
to end in a kiss
[Music]
and joining jack will be recently
escaped from the nursing home
bill belichick
broadcasting from the move it's tom
brady
with not one white hair on his head like
how
dear lord does brady have infinity
gauntlets on both hands
i guess that explains him playing nobody
because he wiped the entire league into
oblivion
except for kaepernick he's been
available this entire time
for [ __ ] sake can somebody please sign
cap
he deserves it wait a second
is that gronk coming out of a portal and
stick around for the halftime show
headlined by the cryogenically unfrozen
carrie underwood on top of a robot
spider